talking ukraine with about a dozen world
leaders justin trudeau stopped in four
countries in four days
it's been about solidarity and alignment
amongst
leaders across europe and indeed around
the world
but more than that it's about concrete
support that includes 117 million
dollars to help more ukrainians reach
canada new sanctions and an extension of
canada's nato mission in latvia but
according to government sources speaking
before the trip the goal was also to
push ideas forward and launch new ones
with maximum impact to stop russia
though there was no public evidence of
that are there new ideas being discussed
behind the scenes that you just can't
share
yes there are
we need we need to work on them with our
partners because
that's how we can be most effective a
senior government source pointed to time
with the new german chancellor as
especially key trudeau and olef schultz
spent an unscheduled three hours
together wednesday night the germans
really wanted to talk to us canada's
former ambassador to germany peter beam
says a lot happens behind closed doors
and being face to face makes a big
difference
you cannot do everything on a platform
that is virtual you can't go into the
corner with your fellow leader whether
it's boris johnson or mark ruta and say
look
can we start thinking about
long-term aid and humanitarian flows
what about
a global food crisis considering that
ukraine is the seventh largest
grain exporter simply having the
personal relationships with leaders
allows you to then react that much more
quickly when the next crisis point comes
as opposed to
yeah we zoomed once in 2020 and uh so
now we're going to do life and death
decisions together this former canadian
ambassador to ukraine says most nato
leaders are in a dilemma about what to
do next this trip didn't solve that
dilemma
because it's a very difficult one
while the opposition calls for more
action canada needs to have some more
concrete examples
of what we can do we need to make sure
that we are prioritizing defense
spending new democrats want more aid and
easier immigration pathways
it's important he's there he's at those
tables that he's participating
should they and could they have done
more and can do more 100
pushing back against russia while no one
can predict vladimir putin's next move
abigail beeman global news ottawa